[Musique]
étranger
je suis content que vous m'ayez demandé j'en ai marre
de mon dos
je n'ai jamais pensé à moi de cette façon
[Musique]
ils en tireraient le meilleur parti s'ils l'
écoutaient dans l'ordre
et  alors ils pourraient faire ce qu'ils veulent
bien sûr je ne suis pas là pour les
faire écouter de cette façon je pensais juste
qu'ils apprécieraient
plus s'ils écoutaient tout le long
parce que les chansons sont dans un
ordre très spécifique
j'aime vraiment deux guitares basse  et
beaucoup de batterie euh
quand j'ai un bon guitariste avec moi
et que je peux en trouver un qui interagit de
sorte que vous ayez une grosse guitare
qui est mon son préféré, c'est pourquoi
j'aime deux guitares et une basse et une batterie
comme ma configuration préférée
bien celles-ci  les chansons sont en grande partie le
produit de huit ans avec ronald
reagan
et l'héritage
qu'ils disent qu'il nous a laissé je suis très mécontent
de l'héritage
et mon disque parle d'une
partie de l'héritage qu'il nous laisse
et que je suis sûr que george bush  va
continuer à nous donner
bien c'est dans le cadre de la chanson
c'est
t  la statue de la liberté a toujours été
debout c'était un cadeau d'amis euh
un symbole de liberté et un symbole pour les
immigrés euh les parents de mes parents
étaient des immigrés
comme ma tout le monde qui vit en amérique est
un immigré sauf les
indiens d'amérique
alors euh je  pense que
la promesse que représente la statue de la liberté
donne-moi tu as faim tu es fatigué
tu es pauvre
est trahie par
le gouvernement maintenant
[Musique]
je me suis intéressé à certains
types de choses écologiques parce que
j'ai  une petite ferme à l'
extérieur de New York où ma femme et moi avons
rencontré des difficultés à propos de choses que
vous penseriez qu'en 1989
ne seraient pas un problème, mais elles se sont
avérées être un problème, puis avec la
dernière grande baleine américaine que je voulais en
Amérique, c'est  un pays si jeune je
voulais écrire
un euh je pensais que c'était tellement dommage que tous
les mythes
semblaient avoir été repris comme
j'aurais aimé être le
premier à comprendre comment écrire oedipe
mais c'était déjà pris donc je  recherché
écrire un mythe amérindien
et le transformer en un petit mythe sur
la terre
je ne veux pas entrer dans une discussion
sur la patrie palestinienne
ce qui m'intéressait était
certains fonctionnaires à la fois publics et
à titre non officiel euh en
disant un  chose et puis certains en
font parfois une autre
que je trouve offensante que je trouve
offensante personnellement
et donc je pense que le rock and roll
peut commenter ces choses et ensuite
nous pouvons toujours en débattre
j'espère certainement que oui
depuis que j'ai commencé à faire des disques je
voulais
faire des disques qui plairaient à un
adulte
afin que lorsque vous écoutez le disque,
vous n'ayez pas à éteindre la
partie intelligente de votre esprit
car il y a beaucoup d'
autres musiques sur lesquelles vous pouvez vous amuser
de plusieurs façons et j'aime  cette
musique aussi, mais pour mes propres
disques,
je veux faire quelque chose qui vous engage
non seulement
physiquement mais émotionnellement et
intellectuellement
quand j'étais à l'université,
j'étudiais avec delmore s  chwartz
et philip booth dont le poète et moi étions
également
dans un cours d'écriture créative et puis je
jouais aussi en même temps
[Musique
] dans des bars pour gagner de l'argent
et ce que j'ai fait, c'est que j'ai combiné les deux
parce que j'aimais beaucoup la guitare
et  je pensais juste que ce serait génial de
combiner l'écriture avec
le
bleu de la guitare électrique